I don't know why people just don't say
anything Stars should just say zero
things I'm [__] I have a podcast so
I'm done I'm done anyway I've been
canceled you know it's like fine but
like if you
do movies and that's it hey say
nothing and then when they say silence
is violence go like
this guess I'm Jack the Ripper and skate
away on your La light
shoes I I just like it's so
like that's why Comics dude
Comics I was look at the Matt R
[__] props some Matt
rif it's just like people are like
somebody writes an article some woman
writes an article about how Matt Rice's
punching down dude let me tell you let
me tell you something right now dude
punching down is [__] funny okay
okay these are like so so you're rich
and white what are you supposed to do
what's
up what's what's up you're rich and
white where who you supposed to punch at
Elon and that's it who you supposed to
punch at Jesus Christ now you start a
holy war who the [__] are you supposed
to oh oh youo Matt re is punching
down dude he's 28 and he's white and
Rich what's
up like what are you talking about and
by the way punching down is funny as
[__] you ever see a [__] fall what are
you supposed to
do poor guy dude it's
funnier you know what I'm
saying you ever see a fat person fall in
like a big puddle
what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to do oh but there's an obesity
problem no dude I laugh hard whoops they
fell
extra I you know it's so here's the
thing you want allies in the game then
stop complaining about [__]
everything and now whoops too late don't
push
me now I get to laugh hard when fat
people fall there we go
and here's the other thing oh no
Chrystal Leia said this no this is dude
the people they don't give a [__] they
like that I'm saying
it don't let me get
Brazen it's all fake dude it's all fake
so you
know props also here the other thing is
is like these these younger this younger
generation they live CRA they don't give
a [__] about anything but clicks bro
they're
crazy look at what Logan Paul was able
to
do bro he's got a [__] hydration
drink he sold a billion
bottles jokes on you
[Music]
[__]